[Music]
welcome rangers you may approach the
patreon
two
when there were 50
gold logic says i should turn you away
that there aren't enough of you left to
do the job at hand
but that dorsey amber the dorsis didn't
just attack you
they attacked my city
this one was
trying to burn down our jail
you'd be my guest
well done
i wish i could give you all the dorsis
and maybe
before in addition to this base and the
eight i promised you it's not enough
i know
the men and women you lost can never be
replaced but it's what i can give you
vengeance is fine honorable even
just now
introductions
my name is saul buchanan
i own colorado
though you'll meet some who disagree
this base is your new home
from yes joe pardon
patriarch
it's daisy an update on the garden of
the gods all right
sorry ranger two of my best are waiting
for you inside darius kwan of the
marshalls and my old friend sergey
graciki go see him i'll be in when i'm
done here
welcome rangers i'm marshall darius kwan
and this here's sergey good to meet you
rangers glad to see some friendly faces
been rough around here these last few
days
dorsey's attacked us too
no idea
something must have triggered how you
deal with them is your call
your base thanks
i can hardly hear myself
oh
completely
[Music]
i think
well done rangers good to see the place
up and running
now where were we
as you may know i have a daughter and
two sons liberty
valor and victory
they've been skulking in the shadows
ever since but lately there's been
rumors that i'm on my last legs
lies of course
but apparently my dear children believe
him peace
i'm not worried about my children
defeating me rangers they won't not even
liberty what worries me is the
destruction they'll reek that's why they
have to be stopped before they can start
and when i say bring them home i mean
bring them home alive
good
then let me tell you where they are
victories hold up in aspen
what do you want to know
that's why it's
no about to get
now he's on the radio
you'd better
good
what else do you need of course she's
having trouble rousting some door why
don't you go give her a hand show us
what the rake hockey all right
let's move out